monsieur Macron vous c'est le business
vous êtes le business et vous êtes
d'accord avec tous ces gens vous êtes
d'accord avec tous ces gens c'est gérant
les actionnaire vous vous êtes d'accord
avec eux non je défends les entreprises
parce que sans entreprise il a pas
défendez quoi
[Musique]
çaende quo donnez le
microi al é au gouvernement il était au
gouvernement il a fait ses
[Musique]
lo pas
inv
[Musique]
contination
continueation il y a pas de
travail a pas de travail vous voulez
qu'on fe des formations pour baisser le
taux de chômage c'est tout ce que vous
voulez mais derrière Onura pas de
travail
TR simpement je ce matinic je l'ai dit
ce matin l'intersyndical ça dépend de
quel argent on par quand on parle du
crédit d'impôt
compétivité quand on parle des crédit
impôt recherche quand on parle des
alligements de charg ou d'impôt des cade
pour le patron mais on n pas d'accord
làdus Mo je dis des
cadeur on
payeret c'est quel chose des Mar
peretreises qui le peu du coup de
réember làus on est pas d'accord
jeassume mais attendez donc ça je vais
pas leur demander de le rendre ça n'est
pas possible même légalement par contre
s'ils ont touché des primes
d'aménagement du territoire des aides à
la des aides ponctuelles pour investir
et autres on leur redemandera comme à
toutes les entreprises qui délocalisent
après les avoir toucher mais je vais pas
vous je vous fais pas de fauses
promesses pas de cicou des choses comme
ça des aides ponctuelles ils ont investi
mais le combat ils ont acheté des des
liges et ils sont ils ont réinvesti ici
en 2016 rendezte ils repartent avec bien
non mais ce que je voudrais et ils vous
doivent rien ils repartent avec ils vous
doivent Ren je sais très bien donc moi
je vous ai dit qu'elles étaient pourb
les combats que je voulais mener